what's up everyone it's Warren and it
seems like the final reshoots for
avengers endgame aren't officially done
yet some of the actors are back in front
of the cameras doing some additional
photography and this has been confirmed
because some of those actors have posted
on their social media accounts now if
you are trying to avoid any and all
potential spoilers for Avengers in game
you may want to click away now before I
start talking about these actors that
are back for additional photography and
what it could mean for Avengers in game
so Karen Gillan the actress who of
course plays nebula tweeted watching the
blue from under my fingernails one more
time
hashtag endgame so nebula is one of the
characters doing additional photography
and so is nebula sister Gamora yesterday
zoe saldana who of course plays Gamora
posted this photo to Instagram of her
back in hair and makeup as Gamora with
the caption can't get enough of her she
then followed that Instagram post up
with another Instagram post which was a
video of her taking off all of the
makeup that it takes to play Gamora the
caption for this one hair up what goes
on must come off
adios Gamora for now at least ha so the
characters Gamora and nebula are back
for additional photography and it seems
like they went back at the exact same
time so could this mean that they are in
a scene together in Avengers endgame it
is believed that Gamora and nebula are
going to be huge characters and Avengers
in game they're both daughters of Thanos
and they both know him better than
anybody else does so could the two
daughters of Thanos be the key to
defeating him in the comics nebula
actually gets the gauntlet from Thanos
and she undoes the snap and although
that's very unlikely to happen in the
movie she could play a part in getting
Gamora back we know that the soulstone
has the ability to control souls and the
time stone could even bring her back
much like Thanos did with vision and
since nebula knows Santos better than
anybody who's alive right now she's
probably the only one who could track
down Thanos and we already know what the
snap cost Thanos everything it costs him
probably the only person he's ever loved
his daughter Gamora
so it's possible
that nebula could find him and tug on
his heartstrings to get him to bring
Gamora back or she could find him and
somehow managed to get the Infinity
Gauntlet or a few Infinity stones away
from him there's a lot of speculation
but based on the fact that these two
characters are doing additional
photography for Avengers in game they're
most likely going to be in a scene
together which means it'll probably be a
pretty important scene and that might
also mean that Gamora comes back somehow
which I don't think is a pretty big
surprise to anybody I think we all know
that but what do you all think about the
fact that these two actors are doing
reshoots for their characters and do you
think that Gamora and nebula are going
to have huge roles and Avengers endgame
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and my new Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway still continues if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you